Hello and welcome to the second video in our course about
Perception Component and the Environmental Query System.
And we're going to jump into the project that hopefully you already have up and running.
And we're going to start the first exercise.
So here we are in the project.
And when on the first slide of the training aid.
Well, we're going to immediately go and jump to the second.
And all this is going to do is bring me to a small example level
where I can see something up in the valley.
Now, if I was to push the simulate button, you'll see that we have a singular AI here
or actually got three that are just wandering around.
Now in this, I'm going to add the Perception component to them
and I am going to get them to chase the player when they see them.
So let's have a look at what we've got here.
So the first thing is a state tree.
And this is what is running the logic on the AI.
We'll double click and open that up.
It's very simple.
Its default out of combat is to just wander around.
And I'm adding in some functionality for it to chase the player.
So when it sees the player, it's going to chase the player.
And when it loses the player, it's going to travel to the last known location.
Now, what's good to note here is that we have a transition
to the chase player and the lost player and back to the chase player.
Here we have these transitions and they are based on looking at a evaluator.
So in this, the evaluator is getting data from a pawn.
So we are going to be using the pawn perception to update these values.
And then we're using these values to move throughout the state tree.
Okay, so let's have a quick look at getting that working.
Now, what I would like you to do is I'd like you to double click and open up the AI site.
And that's going to bring us into our AI.
But what I would like to do is come up into the components panel in the top left here
and push the add button.
And for this, I'm going to search for the AI perception.
I'm going to add this in as a component.
Now, when I added it in, in the details panel, I have a number of options.
At the start with this is going to do nothing at all.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to set this up.
And the main section that we care about in this is the sense config.
If I come down into the sense config and push plus,
it's going to give me a singular array item.
If I have a drop down, it's going to ask me which sense I want to set up.
You can see we have damage here in predictions like team and touch.
For this, I am looking for the site config.
Now, once I've selected that, I can drop down and I have some more options to set up.
At the start here, we have the site radius.
I'm going to change that to 750.
So I want to be able to demonstrate this.
And it's quite a large radius.
It's not easy to demonstrate.
And that's how far you'll be capable of seeing.
And underneath that, I have the lost site radius.
I'm going to change that to 1000.
So this means after your pawn exceeds 1000 away from it,
it is going to mark it as lost as a site.
Next up, we have the peripheral vision off angle.
And this is set to 90.
And this means you'll be able to see everything that is around
in front of the character.
I want to make this a smaller cone.
So I'm going to set this to 45.
And one last thing I'm going to do is under the detection by affiliation,
I'm going to turn on all three of these to make sure we don't get any problems with that.
They come around the rods and cells that you might like to change.
One of them is, for example, point of view backwards.
And what this does here is it will push the cone backwards.
So you've got a bit more of a close peripheral vision for your character.
And the max age, everything there looks fine.
We have a dominant sense option here.
And we're going to leave that as none for the time being.
We only have one sense set up, but that's primarily designed in case you have multiple senses.
You only want to choose the most dominant one when you're reporting it.
Now I'll hit compile and save.
Now that we have something set up, this is a good time to talk about the AI Debug mode.
So the AI Debug mode you can go into whilst you're playing by hitting the apostrophe key.
Now, the apostrophe key is usually to the right hand side of a standard QWERTY keyboard.
It is not the tilde key, which is in the top left, which often causes some confusion.
Once you are in debugging mode, you can then use the number pad 0, 1, 2, 3, and 4
to turn on and off Debug Display modes.
The one that we're going to be looking at here is
number pad 4, the display of the AI Perception Debug information.
So I'm back in the level here, and I deleted a couple of the AI characters.
That's just a singular AI site.
Well, this is just so that we can see the debug code working.
OK, so if I now press play rather than simulate, if I hold down the apostrophe,
you can see in the top left hand corner, it now tells me the very AI debugging mode.
I'm going to push 4, and now we can see the site that the character had.
We can see the distance that it would lose perception,
and we can also see the angle that it can see with it.
So if I stand here, he's going to clock me, and you can see that we have the green dot following.
Now, if I was to come out of perception,
it's still going to register the last known location, as you can see over there.
We're going to use that in order to make a more smart movement.
The main thing to understand is when we go in front, the character is going to pick up on us.
When we go outside of the red one here, it's going to stop,
and it will re-log us when we're back in front like this.
So it's a really useful mode to just see how it's functioning at any one time.
OK, now the problem that we have is our character is not following our character.
He can see him, but we're not actually logging the site at all.
For this, we are going to need to do a bit of coding.
So we'll jump into that in the next video,
but just make sure that you have the AI site character in here,
and that there is a finished version inside the finished directory,
but that's not the one that we want at the level.
We want the AI site one, because this is what we're going to be putting the code onto.
OK, thank you very much. That brings us to the end of this video.
In the next one, we'll be writing the code to log the site of the character
so that it can be used within the state tree.